and you work for cnn and then i think
early october 2021 of last year you guys
had a breakup and then you left the
democratic party to start a new
political party tell us how you came to
that conclusion oh i'd love to so
running for president i treated it like
a startup and when people said to me
it's like oh how are you doing this
it'll be like look when you start
something new you know this patreon i
mean i imagine a lot of people listening
to this know this
uh you're looking at devoting five to
ten years to make it work or to see if
it's going to work so in the context of
politics i was like it's three years and
i was like i can do anything for three
years you know three years a breeze
[Laughter]
like worked at startups for a lot longer
than that uh so i learned a ton on the
trail and then after i came off the
trail i still had this sense of
foreboding where i was like it still
feels like our country is stuck
and so i i dug in uh and to try to
figure out why we feel so stuck and this
goes back to why i think you were trying
to get obama and trump together
is that it turns out our two-party
system is a big reason why we feel stuck
uh you have
a country that's more polarized than
ever if someone's fourth and someone
else has to be against it 42 percent of
americans now see the other side as evil
don't want their kids to marry someone
of the other party i mean party is
taking the place of what used to be
religion in american life when you talk
about racism
or or race
uh and so with this as the backdrop and
by the way it's one reason i appreciate
what you all do is that the media is
part of this social media is part of
this it's just trying to tribalize us
and separate us into camps and so i
concluded look
no matter what you're for the two-party
system is just going to make things
worse over time it's going to turn us
against each other you need to go back
to first principles and if you look at
the founding fathers of the u.s they
weren't freaking partisans or democrats
or republicans they thought political
parties were toxic and terrible
so the question is how do we get from
this dysfunctional duopoly to a more
functional system and i thought well you
need to start a functional third party
uh and then i i don't have it in me to
be like oh you should do this and then
not do it myself particularly if i'm one
of the most logical candidates to
actually do it
[Laughter]
so that's so this is during 2020 when we
were all inside for kovid i was doing
this research and coming to this
conclusion that the us needs to get
beyond the two-party duopoly uh and move
to a multi-party system did you ever
have a meeting with michael porter and
catherine gayle cause that's also what
they talk about yes catherine on like
two years ago or year and a half ago
both of them on oh that they were a
profound influence on my thinking and
anyone who you should go back and listen
to that conversation you can also read
their book the politics industry
industry of politics i think some like
yeah i think the politics industry where
they break down
the politics industry as if it was a
business where you look at it and be
like okay like why does it seem so
dysfunctional why is so broken and what
they concluded was it's not that
politics is broken it's that politics
does not exist to actually solve
problems it exists to provide
jobs for politicians it exists to
provide jobs for consultants
it exists
for these media organizations to gin up
audiences
and so when you make that leap where
you're like okay the purpose of politics
is not actually to do good things
uh then you conclude the same thing that
catherine and michael concluded and
those of you don't know michael's a you
know harvard law professor who was one
of the godfathers of management
consulting uh and they concluded that
look the incentives are broken they need
to be fixed and what they recommend is
non-partisan open primaries to open it
up very interesting and then uh combine
that with the ranked choice voting
process you can choose whoever you want
so those two things are the foundation
of the forward party which i started
which is to say look
uh we just need to have a more
functional rational system that doesn't
uh amplify the extremes at the expense
of the fifty percent of us who are in
the middle somewhere if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]